le théâtre à l'honneur pendant trois
semaines à l'espace albert camus de
maurepas esprit convivial populaire et
culturelle voilà les ingrédients du
festival plein feux sur les planches qui
revient pour une cinquième édition nous
avions une forte demande de la part des
associations et théâtrale de mort par un
et du coup voilà c'est la décision a été
prise ya cinq ans de leur proposer un
mois théâtre et 4 3 4 5 associations
pouvaient se présenter sur ce mois là en
fonction des dates possibles cette année
quatre troupes fouleront les planches
des théâtres mort pas y un sytème tandem
la claque ou encore la plus ancienne la
troupe du crâne
ce sont toutes et tous des amateurs qui
vont s'illustrer dans des pièces très
variés on leur propose une résidence
d'une semaine avec leur met à
disposition les moyens techniques de la
salle des avis de professionnel de
manière à peaufiner leur leur spectacle
et donc elle sera en fin de semaine elle
se présente au mur païen et à ceux qui
veulent venir
l'occasion pour ces compagnies de
présenter leur spectacle de manière
professionnelle
rendez vous le 18 janvier pour la
première date avec la troupe du crâne et
sa comédie les gugusses la compagnie la
claque enchaînera le 25 janvier avec
c'est pas ça le plus important